After school, I like to go on the computer to play my favorite game...
...and chat with my friends.
One day, I got a mean message from one of my friends called Katie.
She said I was stupid for not liking Justin Bieber...
...and she didn't want to be my friend anymore.
I felt really sad because I thought Katie was my best friend.
Mom keeps the computer in the kitchen so she can keep an eye on me...
...and when she saw I was upset, she asked me what was wrong.
I told her what had happened...
...and she was shocked that Katie would say that to me.
Mom called Katie's house and spoke with her mom.
When Katie's mom spoke to her,...
...Katie said she had given her password to some of her other friends...
...so they could use the website.
One girl called Melanie doesn't like me and she had used Katie's password...
...to send me the mean messages.
Katie's mom asked her to change the password...
...and promised that she wouldn't give it out to anyone else ever again.
She said it's really dangerous...
...to give other people any of your passwords...
...because you don't know what they'll do with them.
Melanie's mom got cross with her...
...and she said sorry for sending me the mean messages.
Katie said sorry for giving out her password...
...and I'm really glad we're still friends.
Together, we can make cyberspace a better place.